hello everyone
welcome to this webinar title navigating
the pandemic
design as a career i'm silly from the
design singapore council
and i will be your mc for this afternoon
during this webinar
you can expect to be engaged in a lively
conversation where leaders in the design
tech and other sectors share their
perspectives on how individuals can plan
for their career in design
the opportunities for individuals who
wish to pursue a design career
and the emerging and in-demand skills
that individuals should develop to stay
relevant in this post-pandemic era
before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few things to keep today's
session running smoothly
during this webinar your microphone will
be on mute
however we welcome questions throughout
via the zoom q a function
when posting a question please state
your name and company or school
if you have a specific panelist whom
you'd like to direct your question to
do indicate so as well should you
encounter any technical
issues please reach out to our technical
team via the zoom chat function
we ask for your patience and
understanding should conditions be less
than perfect
i will now share with you the program
outline which consists of
firstly an introduction to the event and
the panel
a self introduction by each member of
the panel
the panel discussion and q a session
which will be the highlight of today
and last but not least a resource
sharing segment by the design singapore
council
and the lifelong learning institute
which covers the support available for
individuals to further their formal
education
and skills development in design
moving on to the introduction we are
pleased to share that this event is
presented to you by the design singapore
council in partnership with the lifelong
learning institute
and supported by the national design
center through this collaboration
we hope to raise awareness and interest
in design encourage a spirit of
condition
continuous learning and help our
students and job seekers get a head
start in exploring a career in design
you may also wish to note that this
event is part of the national design
center's
design learning program lineup for
february 2021
as for the panel we are excited to have
mr ryan lim
founding partner of qed consulting who
will be moderating the conversation with
speakers from both design and non-design
companies
namely miss crystal chu creative
director of kingsman exhibits
mr dale newt hey dot ui head of ux ui of
tomorrow design bank at uob
mr jason go design director of the
experience design group at dell
technologies
and mr yong jiew principal designer and
founder of stuck
i will now pass the time over to ryan
and the speakers on the panel for them
to do a self-introduction
over to you please ryan hi
good afternoon my name is ryan as julie
just mentioned i am the founding partner
of qed consulting as well as your
moderator panel um panel moderator
actually for today
um can i go on to the next slide piece
so just a little bit more about me i am
a practitioner
in dealing with consulting work or in
areas of digital marketing and
communications
i've been doing that for almost 20 years
and i'm also a skills future fellow
next please yes i'm an entrepreneur so i
actually get to get very creative
in terms of what i do especially with
the consulting work and advisory
and i do a lot of uh startup mentoring
as well
on the side so i'm literally a
consultant by day
educator by night i currently at john
lecture at
ntu as well as the singapore institute
of technology
handling both their undergraduates as
well as the master's program for
communications
so a little bit about the the the
company i work with
and uh what exactly did we do oh we
we handle a lot of uh marketing and
communication roles and
uh issues and we actually help
organizations who invest
in that particular space deal with their
design as well as the structure of the
organization
especially to be future proof to be
resilient
and to also tap on and to leverage the
opportunities that
the digital landscape presents itself as
well as to mitigate the risks that is
usually associated with it
so our role actually covers quite a bit
of design of the roles and
processes that comes along where all
when you're investing a lot of time and
effort
into the digital landscape as well as
digital marketing as well as
communication
now that's all enough about me i'm going
to hand over to crystal who will then do
introduction about herself as well
crystal hi everyone
good afternoon to you i'm crystal i'm
the creative director of
kingsman um research and design team we
call ourselves
krmd and you know we are the creative
arm of kingsman group
i hold an honest degree in museum
exhibition design
and graduated also
from thomasic poly doing interior
architecture and design
i have actually more than 21 years of
experience in the design industries and
my portfolios include multiple
attractions of shangri-la group
galleries and museums for national
heritage boards
theme parks for universal studios as
well as experience center innovation
centers
for changi experience changi airport
group
and i'm actually a member of design
education advisory committee
of uh design singapore kauser
ministry of trade and um industry as
well as the members of design
media i can the make advisory committee
at the institute of technology technical
education
and i participate very actively and
contributing some insights to
singapore design education
okay next yeah
placement research and um design the
creative arm of kingsman group we are a
multi-discipline
experience design studio and we um
have more than 200 designers connected
across
10 studios in asia pacific and neither
is
we create experience and we develop
the understanding of underlying needs of
the target audience
next
and um yeah we um
create experience that bring people
together
next
and also um next leave a lasting
memories
um sorry can you hear me now okay
and uh and moments that matters to them
we are storytellers and we believe
that story is actually the most powerful
ways to communicate
we create experience that immerse our
visitors in spaces that engage them
physically
and emotionally we're not just spatial
thinkers but we are designers who
establish
an idea with conviction and we create
experiences that you know that last
moments
and lasting memories for our end user
okay so who we are we are a
comprehensive street of services
that are held under one roof and our
multi-disciplinary design studio
actually brings together
architects designers branding
specialists as well as
creative storyteller
and we create memories
and a memorable experience for all
different sectors
from museum and um visitor centers to
exhibitions and events
retail and corporate interior as well as
attractions and playskate
we believe that every branch has a
unique story to tell
and you know our role is to really make
all these stories comes alive
next please
so you know what is important to us you
know our core philosophy
is really the creative process that it
must be human centered
as such we always say to understand the
needs motivation and behavior
of the end user
and of course how we do it we always
believe that the creative process
is an integrated one the synergy between
design
content as well as digital
really allow us to conceptualize a very
compelling experience
and nice so as a multi-disciplinary team
we are able to think across
in terms of integrated customers
experience across all touch points
content and storytelling brand and
spatial design
digital communication and
personalization we believe that all
these experiences help to shape and
under
define and create lifelong learning
memories for our end user
so a little bit on some of the projects
that we've done
next um i've actually just um
highlighted some of the key projects
that we've completed recently dhl
innovation center on via stream
top left in chicago yeah actually enable
dhl to closely engage their customers as
well as partners industry stakeholder
on the future of logistics in america
changing experience studio on the
right side top is telling a brand story
using a travel guide working with rfid
technology very exciting
to have a look at uh digital if you are
vulnerable is really a very exciting
experience
and um by centennial on the bottom left
it is bringing you back in time to
witness the key moments of singapore
transformation
more than 700 years and to really
identify
and transform see the transformations of
singapore
from as early as um one two nine nine
and uh the right side is actually a
tencent headquarters in shenzhen
that articulate the future forward
principle of the global
vision next
then we talk about nerf action
experience
one of the most exciting project that uh
kingsman's owned as well as create right
from the beginning the entire experience
is a nerf branded attractions that
provide fun-filled experiences
in this multi-team arena and of course
the monopoly dream
on the left is also the first world
attraction to bring hash bro
to the board game which everybody is
familiar with to light
and butts by shangrila on the top right
corner
is actually an imaginative social
experience play incorporated
collaborative and educational play and
we believe
that you know all these powerful moments
doesn't just happen by chance
it is really for us to create
okay next and
yes we are the creator of experiences
and i hope we can share with you more
of our experiences later during our
panel discussion
so i'll hand over to our very
inspirational
and charming deal the head of ux and ui
tomorrow digital bank you will be
thanks crystal thanks for the
introduction um okay uh
hi everyone um so i'm dale i'm currently
a head of the ux ui design team for
tomorrow uh which is a digital bank uh
primarily aimed at millennials and we're
currently in
uh thailand and indonesia um so a quick
backstory of
my background i've been working in the
design industry for close to 18 years
and primarily on digital experience and
and the industry has changed
enormously during that time frame and
i've been fortunate to work for
experienced design agencies and in-house
mostly in-house
in particular over the past 10 years i'm
currently working in
i would say the second industry i've
been exposed to seeing what digital
disruption can actually do uh for the
better and certainly a great thing for
for the design community
um and and i'd say the first time i
experienced that digital
disruption is when i worked for a news
organization news international in the
times
and despite very different industries i
saw very similarities of where
you really have to innovate and change
because the competition and the
environment and the quality of
experience has improved so much
these organizations have to change
within and and design is really a key
kind of catalyst for that
to take place i've also been lucky
enough to work in television
so worked on for sky which is a quite
large tv
network in europe and designing
something similar to netflix
and also designing for mobile and tablet
and they will interact with each other
so full ecosystem
of of the way in which content can be
presented but what i want to talk about
today is is
we're actually just focused about where
i am at the moment and the team that
we're working with and what really
strikes me is that
in in this field of digital experiences
and even
the work banking while designing a
digital product this is a
in many regards quite a golden age of
design and
what i think is really interesting is as
the industry's grown and matured
there are a lot of nuances to the roles
so i thought to share how our team is
structured
just about the different skill sets and
just a high level view of what they do
just to give a perhaps that could be
quite helpful for you to kind of see
the various different types of design
skill sets that now exist
uh so if you're able to move to the next
slide
uh this not so great picture of me with
blue jumper on the right um
what is exactly is the design team well
we are a centralized design team
and it's quite a common model in a lot
of organizations so if you imagine
in my case it's a digital bank and the
way in which you organize
uh the organization is is around the
different experiences you could have a
team from boarding
for banking cover team transact now what
design team is a service provider
so you're always looking at the
end-to-end experience you're always with
the customer lens in mind
not just specific to an area so your
role is to articulate the ideas around
the business with various different
means
from the idea of research into executing
also collaboration is key with design i
think the days of design working in
in silo doesn't really work it's really
about having the cross-collaborative
teams different skill sets working
together simultaneously
so the picture on the right was when we
did a design hackathon and we often do
that and we do like our own little
tailored t-shirts
unfortunately i didn't get the memo on
that day that's why i'm wearing this
blue skimpy jumper which
wasn't my finest hour but we have a very
kind of
fun engaging but hard working kind of
culture in the women's design team
which is quite common to find in in
design cultures in large organizations
if you move to the next slide so i just
want to just give a sense of
what we deem as our kind of four pillars
of design so you have discovery delivery
operations and content so discovery is
really the term for your research to
make sure that we're designing and
building the right things for our
customers at the right time
delivery is more about the execution so
the design is that we're going to
execute the interface the journey
the visual aspects of it all the
functionality the actual execution of
the product itself
and then design opera operations which
comes from the thing called devops which
you may know
which is really exceptionally important
thing for design to ensure in a company
where
it's it's a way of scaling design around
the business organization with the right
tools and methods so it isn't just
design working on its artifacts in its
own
but it's referenced around the business
so it's weaved into the over
organization i'll talk about a little
bit more moment
and then content design um you may have
heard of marketing content writers
this is more experience usability
content writing and the difference is
that is rather than writing aspirational
content you're really
riding it along the journey the
experience writing useful relevant
delightful content
that's part of the experience almost
like conversational design
i think it's been a missing pillar to a
lot of digital design over the past 10
15 years
be able to move to the next slide
thank you okay so design discovery um
it's an
incredibly broad church uh you may hate
uh human cent design design thinking
and really it's an array of uh a site um
quite a variant palette of different
tools and methods to do your research
so it's very much about label educate
and power now discovery has been really
key to actually driving design
having it seat at the table become more
empowered
and expectations and this has been a big
shift it's one of the reasons why we
need a lot of
designers in this field and really it's
about how let's say for instance the
business has an idea but i have no idea
what it means for a product
how do you get from a business idea to
something that's meaningful to a
customer
to a product in the hands and really
discovery is that first part
really understanding human lens and and
as a design team we facilitate that but
you create these cross-collaborative
teams where you bring people involved
around the business
and you take them through this process
so you get the shared understanding that
design you're also trying to educate the
business how to understand
from the customer's perspective if we
move to the next slide
here it's great so design delivery has
said this is really about the execution
so
if you're working for a large
organization if there's a new feature or
a new product
a new experience a small change it comes
to the design team we have to make sure
is this thinking about the customer how
does this fit into the interface
visually and functionally speaking and
also about scalability so
when you're designing now it's more
complex you've got to think about
is it right for the different markets is
it going to translate well for different
devices it could be an apple watch it
could be a mobile tablet it could be a
standard web experience
you have to be able to design thinking
about these things if you move to the
next page
so what is design operations said so
this is really about how you mature the
tools so the large organization
you have the business and different
roles in that you have design team you
have the developers
and you have what's called sit and uot
testers which is a way to make sure
what's being built is correct
all these different functions need to
have a reference of what is the kind of
source of truth for design
so one is more of a mature process but
also there's a thing called a design
system
if you're looking at a website or a
phone or any different device you're not
really seeing isolated interfaces
it's a way in which you can build all
the language all the components and the
patterns
and the way that could be referenced and
used on all these different experiences
so it's really about a way which we can
scale the execution of design
if we move to the next page
thank you so as i said content design
this is a really key pillar
you can have the best visual designers
really well thought out ux designs good
research
but if you can't translate the content
correctly an experience as fails
so much of content design is
understanding voice and tone so if you
look at a large
organization that successfully gets
their content right
you feel that it's their voice but it's
not from just marketing aspirational
talk
it's knowing where you are on the
journey what is the pain point where is
the moment i need to be direct to you
when is the moment i need to be
empathetic towards you
is having that intelligence and working
with the visual designers to know how to
do that
and that obviously impacts the real
estate of the screen as well
and also this is another branch of
design empowering the business because
this is also a way that
we have to educate and facilitate around
the business that different teams
understand how to do that
and that's a great empowerment and value
to design as well
so if you move to the next page which
can be quick
so i'm just giving it this is just a
small example of a team but i just
wanted to share this to
to show the variety of different skill
sets just within design
you have cross collaborative teams with
more skill sets but this is just looking
at design
so design delivery you have a design
lead you've got ux designers which is
obviously the
looking at the overall experience and
functionality taken from the research
ui designers how to actually visually
craft it there is a lot of overlap and
they do actually work
side by side not just left to the right
and also ux research which is really key
to understanding the data the customer
insights for the research
and then we also have the design system
team you have someone who manages design
ops
and you have what we call design system
designers where they're the ones
designing the system it's about
execution how you scale
and then what we have what's called ux
engineers and this is a rare breed of
developers
you may find designers also learn about
code this is really important that their
main focus is just about how the
interface is built
so it's the bridge between design and
how something is built and combining
those two skill sets together
and being embedded into the design team
so designers know what they can actually
build for
and then knowing how to be creative with
the constraints that you have
and then the content design we have a
content strategist designer
that would look at the customer journey
map and work out how you actually draw
the content correctly of that experience
and then you have content designers
working with the ui designers and ux
designers
when they're creating the experience and
then this thing called visual testing
when you're like my experience when i
was um you know in education that 18 20
years ago when
you know you're designing uh on your own
accord and you finish with this
design that you're happy with from that
point to getting into
something that's built into a customer's
hands is a rather different process it's
very complex and very challenging
so we have visual testers to make sure
that they're regulating governing that
the fact that what's being built is
actually in line to how we're designing
an experience
so i i hope that's been uh helpful and i
hope that's been in
the shortest time possible i'm going to
hand over to
jason a very humble design director from
dale
jason here so today we're going to talk
a little bit about
myself my career journey and also to
help
um you guys can understand the dell
design
experience design group a little bit and
then what we do
here in singapore okay currently i'm
basically serving as a design director
and also the
site lead of the dell experience design
group here
based in singapore so next slide please
so just a little bit about my career
so i've always been in a in the kind of
i.t or or kind of uh the consumer
electronic journey across my um career
so start off with panasonic in the early
days where i kind of grew my kind of a
hard skills and then move on to
siemens video where i basically start to
kind of
design a car audio products and then
creative technology which is singapore i
lead the
um the speaker design team in creative
and then move on to hp where i lead the
asia
team for the printers division and
finally uh with dell
now basically leading the team here in
singapore
all right um next please so uh
a lit a little bit about um dell design
right so
um we we are basically a global
um design team that um design everything
under
the brand of dell and also the
anywhere as a gaming brand right so um
looks like this
so so as um as the company as the team
itself we kind of
aim to deliver and uh enhance people's
experience and life um through
personal and also professional right so
and and i think the design process
itself is pretty
kind of uh stringent from all the way
what we did was basically all the way
from
future right so we have an advanced
design
um team itself that basically looks at
what's coming next right so he's always
ahead of the game
so we have basically um functions like
um
cross-functional teams in this design
like for example
industrial design team we have um
basically user experience we have
basically packaging design right visual
design
cmf and also ui ux
so we kind of encompass the entire kind
of design multiple design function into
one
team itself a next
thank you um our group is basically
located across um the different
regions right so from us being
the headquarter of dell right so in
austin texas and a few cities in us
so we have groups in amsterdam and so in
europe itself and then we have
two groups in asia which is taiwan and
singapore so all these teams itself is
basically located to make sure that the
the
design organization has to attract
talents across
the different regions right so and we
are so closely
kind of neat right and together as a
team so that we could basically
understand the different cultural
differences between the different
regions across the group
right so this is uh i think that the
as the mmc and a big design organization
this definitely helped us to kind of
grow our point of view from different
regions and also basically customers
from different
areas right so and also at training
design talents all over the place
and singapore itself our focus
here in singapore is really to crush the
best in the
best in class dell products and also the
alienware products and then powerful
right so later i'll kind of walk through
with you a little bit more
uh about the products that we design so
but
i think first we want to kind of share
with you a little bit about the team
um nick's like this so this is this is
uh
the team here that um is responsible for
how crafting all
the products under um dell and
also alienware so the we always believe
that
people are at the heart of our kind of
organization and the success of the
company so this is
the the creative theme that basically
helps to make dell success in this area
so and and we also kind of focus on
having a more diverse team as well so if
you can see
um we kind of have talents over
um the the different ethnic groups from
different countries
and and also um gender as well right so
and from this group itself we have three
different uh
that's kind of key functions right um
from design management
industrial design to user experience
also within uh the group here in
singapore
uh next place so for the group in
singapore we kind of focus on
why i say peripherals products across
dell
global we basically design a product
they sell globally so
let's start with gaming right it's more
consumer focus so
gaming is one of the key uh part of
the singapore team as well because we
are responsible for crafting all
the gaming monitors that you see here
under the brand of dell on top of that
we are also basically
i'm designing uh the next site please
the
the alienware peripherals as well so
under the brand
um in the gaming side of the business so
if you look at uh what the singapore
team is responsible for this particular
gaming experience
so we are basically crafting things that
um there's gaming has a couple of things
right like visual
so the monitors itself basically give
you that visual
right so the audio right so piece of the
experience which is um all the
gaming headsets etc that we are
designing here in singapore and also
um the input and touch points that you
kind of control your games which is
basically all the mice and keyboards
right that we basically uh designed here
in singapore so so
the portfolio of uh all the peripherals
like monitor keyboard mics headsets
including um soft goods like bags um
like jackets t-shirts um etc right so
it's designed here in
singapore as well next place so the
other part of um
kind of dell um the biggest part
actually is on the commercial
uh portfolio so dell started off as a
small focus on
commercial where we basically supports
all the
company success and then setting up
their ig improv system
right so dell like commercial monitors
is one of our key focus here in
singapore as well
so we have been number one um in market
share for
monitors for the past like seven years
right so we will continue to kind of
lead the market in this area and
continue to excel and differentiate
ourselves from competition
so next piece so this is a kind of
overview of some of the commercial
monitors that we kind of design here in
singapore
so not only the desk monitors but also
um for example the next slide um you
look at some of the conference room
uh experience and monitors as well so we
do
large format monitors that allow you to
go
pen inking touch and also compute into
that
screen that you install in the in the
conference room
in offices next week so
on top of the monitors itself we are
also
basically in charge of all the
peripherals under the brand of
dell so peripherals means like things
that is surrounding their pc if you look
at this image itself um
other than the pc laptop uh the the kind
of power
charging the running the laptop the
conference speaker
adapter that you see there mines in the
pan they are all designed here in
singapore including the sleeve that you
see at the bottom left corner
right so that's all the accessories uh
that you see
on all the the right uh the naming
they're all designed here in singapore
right uh next base so like i say like
including
um soft goods this is something that is
uh been pretty interesting to the team
as well so that's unique
that we kind of have a unique team that
helps to kind of create a recyclable
materials uh for bags right so so our
dell bags are basically having this uh
eco loop
um kind of a trademark that is uh
more environmental friendly in the
process of producing all these softwoods
so this is the part of the collaboration
between i would say with our cmf team
and also
uh our design team itself to create a uh
eco-friendly software's portfolio so
next place
yeah these are some of the the bags that
we design i think it kind of sum up the
the the whole um like design
products that i mean the product design
that we do here in singapore
so i hope to kind of talk more and share
with you more on
that later so with that i would like to
kind of uh
introduce uh jue which is um the
principal designer and soldier founder
for a local cup design team called stock
hey jerry hi
um yeah thanks jason for the
introduction
hi my name is jay good afternoon and
i kind of co-founded a company called
stuck with a few friends 10 years back
so we are
a design agency or consultancy um
and uh dell and eop are actually some of
our clients as well
um if you can move to the next slide
please
so we um we're homegrown uh we started a
tree in an apartment and today we
have a team of 30 over um and it's a
it's a good mix now so over the years um
we all started as you know product
designers but the team now has grown to
have researchers programmers we call
them prototypers or thinkers
and facilitators um within the team
and we have accumulated over a hundred
clients and more than 400 projects over
the past 10 years
um i'll mix like these so i've been
pressing on my computer
for today maybe just to share a little
bit
about maybe um the career
as well as personal journey right um and
also the mindset i have for
um career is that from career point of
view i think rather than to think that
who
employ me or who are really um who
should i join i like to think from the
anger of
who can i add value to because with that
angle
you would never you never really have to
worry about employment at all
just to share a little bit about the
design industry i think the definition
and value of designers have expanded
quite a bit over the years
um and to illustrate all that um i'll
just share with you the personal journey
and starts career path in
in a sense uh in trying to constantly be
relevant and create value for
people around us and how that has
changed over time
so you can move to the next slide um
so this is where it all really started
um 10 years ago um
three friends in an apartment um we
we graduated we have been working a few
years and we got back to singapore and
at that time um
just thinking maybe you should do
something together but the reason why
they don't look so happy in that picture
pictures because i just beat them in
winning 11 um
over computer games so um so that was
how it all started we came back and
and we really thought of um because we
were trained as industrial designers
which is uh product designers
so we we thought to come together and
offer industrial design services
as a team and looking back i think we
will never imagine the kind of projects
that we will be doing today
and it's really just guided by the kind
of deep passion that we have about
design and kept looking at how we can
find relevance and use design to create
value and impact for people
if you move to the next slide
so example is this one of the recent
projects that has been launched
actually last year this is a typical
product design project
for a local client and um so this is
what we do brad and barter product
design
on the next slide
and over the years as people understand
the value of design and being upstream
to create
products that never existed rather than
to shape a product
we started getting a lot more innovation
work and how that defers is that
there's a lot more upfront creation of a
product that might not have existed
so it could be a new typology it could
be a new product that
wasn't in the market before and the
company might have a certain technology
that they want to imbue into a product
or for a value purpose right
um so we call it innovation projects we
started getting more and more that over
the years
uh next slide and this started um
in 2007 when iphone was launched and you
know the the whole apps industry started
um
you know booming in that sense and
products were getting more connected as
they were called iot era the internet of
things
and that's where we started to build the
team around capabilities to create
products that can connect and we started
expanding
uh interaction team in-house to service
our clients um i think all of this grew
rather organically
we're doing their products so they came
to us and say hey can you do our apps as
well
and that started the whole ui ux
department or rather team
in stuck itself the next slide please
more recently over the past few years
design thinking has been picking up in
locally especially in the government
sector we've been always doing
we've always been doing research for the
mncs the multinationals which
understand the value of research uh to
drive innovation
so we have always been doing um product
driven
kind of research work in different
countries
in emerging markets in indonesia
thailand sometimes in the u.s as well
but more and more you will see that even
government agencies
as well as retail or service providers
they are looking at
understanding the users or understanding
people in general and how can they carve
out
a strategy or guidelines or you know a
pathway moving forward to maybe pivot
their business or change the way that
they work
or create new products and services so
we started going to research and
strategy
this is for um early childhood education
for preschools
so um we're really proud of this project
because that's where we actually get to
define
environments um to create guidelines for
architects and
the government agencies to define how
children
environment or learning preschool
learning environment should be
things like this
and similarly a similar project that
defines
kind of a new model of care for elderly
nursing homes in singapore
which is also a research plus ideation
and as well as strategy and guidelines
for mohh
and ura and all these things couldn't
happen
uh if design was not proliferated or uh
understood of the impact that you can
create and naturally these things were
not done
in silo this one we had the panoramic
architecture firm to uh eventually be
able to build
and they are building this nursing home
design right now next slide please
this is something quite new about two to
three years
new end so as we move from just pure
products into connected products
into technology um kind of innovation
and then moving into understanding that
research and upfront strategy was
important designer's role started
expanding
uh and this was um based on the
connected experiences
um a lot of brands are realizing that um
typical
top-of-line marketing and advertising
isn't working so well with uh very
experienced driven
uh kind of pampered users right so we
are very very used to
good experiences um in the market so
this is where um
we started getting requests from clients
to say can you design my uh
point of sale um kind of tools or kits
so that people can experience my brand
and sometimes their technology is good
but it's so hard to experience or
explain because it's all embedded within
the product like this in this example it
was uh
for nikon uh slr quizlet lens which
a lot of work and r d went into the lens
but it's just transparent it's really
really hard to sell
so we started working with demo two kits
and we call them brand activations where
you started using our understanding uh
innate skills of creating ideas to work
on how
how do you let someone experience the
brand uh in a different manner so that
they can actually um
understand what what what you're you're
doing or you're selling in that sense
um the next slide and along with all of
this
we started um thinking about okay how do
we
keep ourselves ourselves and our clients
continuously um
kind of interested or have a sense of
wonder around the world
so um we started building our own labs
team
uh so we started um doing experiments
and this experience
has no clients um we started to be our
own clients and say
let's just react and create with
whatever
um things that's happening today the new
technology or
the new issues that's that we are facing
and uh
create interaction pieces um to to share
with our clients to share
publicly as well as internally as
inspirational sources
so all in all i think this sums up what
the company does
and how we have shifted um ten years
back you know when we were thinking we
were just going to do products and that
was really truly
what we were thinking when we started a
company and not thinking that we were
gonna
we were even wondering will we survive
the first three years at all as a
business
um the next slide please
um yeah so this is my last night i
thought i would just uh end off
on this slide and i think more and more
people and organizations are
understanding what design can do
and from a career or market perspective
i think it is a definitely
an exciting place to be not only in
singapore but around the world
i remember when i first wanted to study
industrial design my mom was still
telling me that i might not be able to
get a good paying job
um yeah i was i was worried but i
it was what i i liked so i just did it
right um
and i think more importantly the shift
is that we should especially
with the world changing so fast you know
what you need and what
the context of the world is just
changing so fast i think schools are
trying to catch up to train people
to educate people to provide vocational
training that fits the world today
you imagine right four years career for
his education plus
before your first education was even
there there would most likely have been
like
three to four years of planning for the
education so it's a seven to eight years
gap
in between what the word today is and
what the word tomorrow is
so um it's not so much about what school
has originally trained us for
but it's to more focus on how can i
adapt how can i update my skills how can
i relearn
how can transfer what i know to be
relevant and create value for the world
um and because i think if you are really
relevant and you can create value
you you really don't have to worry about
employment at all people will come
looking for you
yeah so i think that's my last life for
today
thank you very much everyone um you've
probably heard all the exciting things
uh that you've shared by our panelists
and you'll notice that the career in
design is
definitely the one of the possible
opportunities that you can now explore
but as with our topic today we want to
know and explore design
uh as a career right not just as a job
and you probably heard from everyone
that the career
roles and paths for all our panelists
today have actually evolved quite a bit
from where they started
to where they are right now and if you
look at it we want to
look at it from or with the lens of the
pandemic right we are actually
in the midst of it we're trying to
emerge out of it and we want to say hey
look how do we actually stay relevant
and and also explore what are the career
opportunities and hear directly from all
our expert speakers today
not only that we are hoping to maybe
chat a little bit about what's the
career path in terms of planning
for a career in design discover what are
the kind of skill sets that's actually
needed as a result of it especially you
want to hear directly from the
practitioners themselves right what
they're seeing in the market space as
well
and last but not least also have some
personal advice
from everyone so now let me ask that
most important questions to kick off
this discussion uh with among all of us
right
what is that career trend that we're all
seeing because it seems we have been
evolving quite a bit
from all the panelists and all of you
that have just shared
from where you were back then and to
where it is right now
where are we hinting towards for designs
professional and maybe i can just start
it off by
directing this question at crystal
crystal what do you think
where are we heading towards
okay so being uh the the rose among
thorns
[Laughter]
okay um so the current trend is actually
very
inspiring you know it's like uh like
what uh it was [ __ ] you know we really
believe
that um design has actually it's just
more than
creating a aesthetic environment now we
believe that is now transforming
business
raise quality of life connect people you
know drive
innovation create new values and design
is not just a skill
it's really a mindset you know help us
to respond to the disruption
and you know we are tasked now not just
to assist our client to create
beautiful architectures but we help our
client to solve problems to capture new
market
you know us at the re uh the projects
that we're working with know the
attractions project when we're working
on shangri-la but
we were involved in helping them to
create um
the activity within the space to work
out their business plan together with
them on how to bring in
more families staycation group within
the business hotel and we were all part
of the whole
um brainstorming process of making the
business work
and especially with this new covet world
you know we
designers have to rethink the way we
work
the way we we live the way we do our
business
and you know it's it's a lot and you
know there's a whole new world
of new experience for us to design so a
lot of potential
for designers right now
dale any any thoughts where are we
heading towards
well i think first of all it was before
whereas now is hugely different i agree
a lot of what crystal was saying i think
that the days of design teams being
a reactionary kind of team that just
delivers visual aesthetics has very much
come to an end for
multiple industries and yet it's it's
driving business decisions and it's
it's no longer in fact it design has
become so important so value that it's
it's too important just to belong with
the designers so a lot of designers now
is knowing how to facilitate all these
ways of working and all the methods that
we have
around the business as a whole and but
yeah i mean the
i think the skills become there's more
titles existing there are different
types of roles existing in design
because it's scaling up to such a
size now and what what really strikes me
i mean i i guess i'm biased from
being in more digital design for some
time but it's still experience design
still design thinking um is is
that still a struggle to find people
with the expertise to fill the gap in
what we need in our teams
you know i generally believe this is a
golden age for design
and i said it is a mindset as well it's
driving business decisions it's driving
what defines a good experience
is bringing the ethical questions into
what design should be about as well
i mean it's changing business
collectively as a whole and and it's a
space a lot of people want to get into
and if you don't adopt a design thinker
you seven design
and you're not really seeing it from
that lens you're most you're running the
risk of coming out with a less quality
outcome
with whatever you're creating and and
the competition will see that and
customers will recognize that
the benchmark has risen so much now so
the need for
more practitioners and designers just
only grown and significantly over 5
years
no even me right has the pandemic sort
of given this design
profession a bit of a speed bump or a
speed boost
to me yeah i would say obviously i'm
working for digital bank right now so
the sense of drop and currencies become
more important
so yeah definitely um i think just the
ways are working
digital products or already digital
experience always
kind of progressing quite strongly but
it's just accelerated that
for sure right um dude jason do you see
the same thing
yeah i think definitely accelerating i
mean i mean the it business
so so i think we i mean and as i t
company there has been always
basically promoting like a seamless uh
working
experience right so be whether you are
in in different countries or locations
you you
have the capability of connecting um
this whole
experience or the workforce itself and
then this pandemic has just
accelerated the adoption of basically
um remote working working for anywhere
right uh concepts right and i t
infrastructure
itself is basically the thing that
basically tie in all those stuff that
allow people to go do that
right so i do see that i mean in dell we
do see that yeah it kind of accelerated
the whole need for the the experience
through
pandemic so has it evolved any
or where do you where do you see that
trajectory going towards
when it comes to the design profession
right so from for us um like for example
we have
kind of moved some of our design
so-called tools like for example
now with the kind of everyone not able
to
share contents or basically touch the
same thing or look at the same thing we
have kind of evolved like for example
from a physical to a digital design
review with ar vr
for example right so you kind of use
technology itself to kind of replace
some of the
the kind of um let's say traditional way
of looking at physical stuff but
basically serving the same purpose
we are using technology to go support um
all these activities
right and then i i want to direct these
questions to you by the way
you have to remind me after this to ask
you for your prototype coffee machine
uh i i enjoy the coffee and everyone
like aesthetically pleasing and i'm
assuming that the coffee will taste just
as good
um but i've seen right what you've just
shared from your introduction that
you've gone on from
very basic uh work into that all into
product design
evolving all the way down to designing
uh the
locations as well as designing as an
experience
i mean you seem to be evolving a lot
very very
huge changes and very integrated to the
business where else what's next are we
going to design dreams as well
no i mean my bed is going to be on
experiences um and
i think it's um like we were just
talking about clubhouse right um
right um and i think it's where the
experience is going to be
then the demand will will follow right
um and
that's where you need a little bit more
subject matter knowledge and skill sets
to go into that area
um and and i think it's not not
something that i think when we think
about a design
designer it's not some individual but
it's it's a team
uh and um as we were saying that i think
they'll point out that it's expanding
right it's expanding and therefore the
the skill and the roles that it has
carved out is quite quite varied right
now
so i think there's no one way to define
that but it's really about that dynamic
and
and five varied roles that's being
carved out because of the new demands
of design so what's next would really
follow on
where the experience lies next if the
frontier of experience lies in audio
if the frontier experience lies in
virtual then i think that's where the
mixed big demand will be
but i'm also betting on authentic
interaction and experiences simply
because we are
fundamentally human um so an example
when you ask about the digital
acceleration and
if you ask where the money is definitely
digital is in huge huge
um gap a gut you know or rather that
there's a huge demand for
uiux designer and programmers simply
because that's where the trend or the
experience is moving towards
um but um they also there's also a
another another point of view about um
people
craving more for authentic human
interactions and experiences
so that's another point where um like
retail is trying to reinvent themselves
service providers um
physical you know businesses are also
trying to reinvent them and that's also
another big area that um
design is going to be needed so i think
it's going to flourish in
multiple areas and not just in one area
yeah yes
and this is actually taking into context
where uh of the pandemic right where
everyone has to rethink
and redesign them so or rather reinvent
themselves as well and
try to figure out what's the new mode of
actually going forward would that be
right to say that
yeah yes um yeah do you think i think
the
the no i think the key thing is more we
we we
i mean for from uh for us we we kind of
basically see that coming right in the
sense we are in the third phase we call
it the phase of um digital
transformation
right so in in the past it's really kind
of uh one at a time meaning all
computers don't talk to one another
you you are location based uh you you
can't work from one area
and you just work from there and go home
it don't work right so all the way to
to current um trend of technology that
is where he's bringing us
it's more collaborative it's more kind
of uh
ubiquitous and stuff right so so those
trends
actually from our that's why i was
saying the team that we have here is
always kind of looking forward what's
next
so that was the trend that we basically
kind of see um like three years ago
when we started to kind of put that
together and say hey in the future this
this will be the trend that is going and
then
as we build our way to it and it just
like why i say pandemic just accelerated
so now things are a little bit more
connected the uh
the blending between digital and
physical environment uh
is is more now right so it's gonna just
mix uh the reality is just going to mix
between digital physical and then and
that that is basically where we're
heading right towards i mean i i've
i noticed that there was a very
interesting question that came out maybe
i can just post this over to all of you
here
uh because it seems that with the roles
expanding i think dale mentioned that
the roles
are evolving and there are more
different roles that is required to put
together into a team rather than having
an individual
so are we heading towards more like the
generalists kind of uh
are we leaning towards being generalists
or are we leaning towards more being
more specialists
uh roles when it comes to design
professions
i i i know my view is is the answer is
i don't think the back of my answer to
that combination of all i think um
one of the reasons why collaboration's
becoming so key is because now we have
more specialist roles
involved however when you're looking at
things human-centered design design
thinking whatever terminology you put to
it's really about
understanding why customers are using
the thing they are what moments about
what value it brings
so whether you start off as a ux
designer or you're working into ui or
some other
design skill set primarily you're
thinking in the same approach
so there's an awful lot of overlap um
and i think so so naturally
if you want to become a design leader
you have to have a general knowledge
about design
and being able to communicate with
designers to the business and people
from different areas different skill
sets outside the design community
and i think also um what you're
mentioning earlier about the fact that
at the moment there's a lot of uh need
for digital design
but you could be ux design in reality
that you're not really about designing
the interface or
i'm gonna build a mobile app it's more
about understanding what that experience
is so it actually translates to a lot of
things
so i see a lot of people going into the
design industry
perhaps starting off as a ui designer
perhaps goes into ux
perhaps goes into content design perhaps
goes into design strategy
or moves up moves up the chain into more
upstream of what design could be
um so yeah i think you start off being
more specialist
but i think once you start getting
exposure of this collaborative culture
you tend to grow into different roles
and you tend to get more involved and a
lot of things across the experience
do you think that there is actually like
an opportunity for two tracks where you
can go
specialists uh and uh journalists as
well at the same time
can they coexist um
i mean i guess sometimes you can join a
design team and your choice is that you
want to remain
a personal craft where that's where you
get the real enjoyment it's actually
doing the
design itself and then perhaps you
become a specialist in a certain area
but if you want to choose to
uh you know try and push design in an
organization
then you have to kind of expand so i
think right going
general could be more be in a sense of
becoming design leadership
but but even a person's craft you still
would expand your skill set
but perhaps you you select a specific
area
then maybe i can i can pose this
question to crystal as well right
uh in your capacity i mean which one
would you be hiring more of in the next
couple of months
the generalists or the specialists
both actually i mean i i honestly think
that uh
um it is like this this whole covert uh
pandemic situation has it has
accelerated innovation
and has accelerated business
transformation and you know we are now
living in a
in a new era where the world is changing
faster than and ever and
um i don't think that's really just a
specialist anymore
is that we really have to um equip
ourselves and really uh
adapt and stay relevant be really quick
in in adapting like uh what they'll say
is all about your mindset you know it's
like how we we
communicate we're still designers who
communicate our thinking our strategy
behind
to our end user so as you know all sorts
of different
experiences that comes in i mean
basically we still want to to achieve as
much as
we can so um whether we're designing a
or fox home or a a kids
child care center it is all working out
not today for the end user so
it is really um basically we have to be
specialized in just creating that
experience
that we mentioned earlier i mean i i
have this uh interesting thought right i
mean
now that there seems to be a there there
was a demand but there is an
insufficient supply
and i'm sure that given the more
creative side of the business there will
always be freelancers right the loan gun
who's passionate develop the skill sets
and themselves do you see this as a
more like for example outsourcing or
partnering some of these individual
specialists who are out of guns for hire
or do you think that is more like
something that you want to hire
within or to get someone within the
organization as a team to
work with you i mean maybe i can throw
this question over to
just an agency who is doing that what
what what's the
what's your thought on this is it would
you partner as a freelance
specialist or would you prefer to hire
in-house
um yeah so um postcode here right um
our team has mostly been working
remotely so and even prior to that we
have been very open with
to partner with um freelancers and um
or even other agencies um locally or
overseas as well
um so that has always been our tna um
but i think that the
decision on whether we are to keep it as
a core team or use it as a
as a partnership will depend on um the
core offering that you are giving right
um
so at the end of the day it will be like
do you need to utilize this um
um kind of um you know skill set
or does that um you know synergize more
things within your company to have it in
house
then that's the decision where should we
buy the bulletin higher uh or do you
need it as
um kind of like an injection of
creativity or
a supplement of skill sets or
capabilities that your
uh team is missing then we use that as
a freelance basis and sometimes we even
use that as education basis
but we know it's um the project budget
might not have afforded a good
freelancer on this project we would
still have a higher one
just so that our team can learn from the
the experience of the freelancer and the
different perspective that's external as
well
so it really depends on a lot of
criterias
right and jason do you hire or partner
i think we do we do both right so but
the
the key yeah i think the the key thing
is more of the specific skill set that
you
need at that point of time right some of
the skill sets that uh uh
our expertise that you kind of need them
might not be
for long term it might be a for a
specific project you need uh
for example a program programmer to come
in and help you with certain things
right so and then you kind of hire them
as a freelancer to come in there but
there's definitely a core competency
that we establish in within the
organization itself
right so to help run the day to day and
then we inject
um kind of creativity with uh with
consultancies or even freelancers that
comes in to help us
kind of take a different pers
perspective
right inject it with a new or creative
uh perspective into the the design
process
right so but we do feel that the
challenge in
in singapore is uh uh we it's hard to
fight freelancers
[Laughter]
with my with my colleagues in uh in
amsterdam they were like nobody wants to
work
as permanent stuff everybody wants to
work as a freelancer so that they could
have flexibility in time
and they are also working for multiple
companies for multiple projects right
but in singapore
or we always try to find freelancers
it's tough
i you know i want i want the kind of
dream job like the digital nomadism
right i want to do
the freelance work for you but drinking
coconut juice in some bahamas somewhere
while
no working for a corporate job at the
same time right and if i'm stressed out
and i need inspiration i can go down to
the jungle
canoe a little bit inspired and come
back to do my job
okay that's not a big one yes deal yes
reasons why uh i mean that if you're
designing a digital product it's no
longer about you design something
it's done it's shipped completed it's
always ongoing it's always iterating
so that's why when we use agencies uh we
tend to have it more embedded now
they're part of the actual team they
don't feel as though they are a
contractor
but as jason was saying sometimes it
could be a specific thing that you need
to up skill on and then you use a
freelancer
um but also find the same issue very
difficult to find
um you know experienced freelancers in
singapore
ah so that's an opportunity for everyone
listening in right so
skill up and be employed and you'll be
extremely valuable and hopefully rich
along the way too
[Laughter]
now i i think all of you here today uh
are actually coming from
a reasonably large size organization and
i'm sure that the
organizations the corporate
organizations the large ones have really
recognized the value
that design as a profession has for the
organization
at the business level but what about i'm
not sure but have you ever encountered
or spoken to people
uh who are working or looking at the
small and medium enterprises themselves
do they value
design as much and what are some of the
challenges that they face
when convincing them of the value of
design to a much smaller
uh organization is there anyone who can
share a little bit about this
yeah yeah oh jason
yeah i think that that that's that's
something that i wanted to kind of uh
uh say as well because i think even from
uh
my friends in the consultancy industry
we they do see that there's a there's a
high uptake of uh
kind of smbs trying to kind of uh bring
in design
to their organization right so by by
basically uh
con engaging a consultancy to to work
with them because they don't have
enough steam to go set it up all right
so especially
with my consultancy friend in china they
do see a growing
kind of needs of sme coming in and say
hey i need i need design
services for my my company i need them
to kind of help
boost up the the product and the design
the experience itself
right so so that's why i did i do see
that booming
yep you can say more
yes please i was like this is uh this is
always quite a heartbeat problem for us
actually um
yeah it's really on relevance um i think
by nature of the business
um mom and pop smes right have a very
short
kind of planning ahead and the budgeting
is also very tight
so when that's why i say design is
really varied right really on depends on
where you're operating at
and with that it also comes to a point
where there is a point where you might
or might not be ready to use design
or that this agency they are looking at
is not suitable for your needs
so it's about relevancy and we have a
lot of clients that actually come to us
and
what we do is we actually refer some of
our friends or some of our um
you know fellow design agencies to them
and say because what you're looking at
will actually not cost effective for you
we are actually costing you money so
we'll tell them go to this one
and they're pretty good at what you need
and um you know they'll get the things
done for you
um so i think it's really about that um
i don't think it's that they don't value
design
but the at the end of the day um the
kind of impact they're hoping to
to to make uh to their business uh can
be very specific
and then therefore the a specific agency
will feed them
i mean having say that we do we a lot of
second intergeneration smes um you know
inheriting from
uh their fathers or family their
businesses and want to transform the
business because um
you know to the way they work digitalize
it or you know create new services
um and then those are the medium or
slightly larger size smes that would be
more ready to embark on certain
um kind of more risk-taking design work
in that sense
so it really depends uh by behind semi
is really uh
rising and i think um the government is
also trying to help up with giving out
grants for that as well yeah
right crystal is there anything that you
have encountered with the sme clients or
prospects that you have deal
is that any difficulty or friction
trying to convince them about the value
or quantify the value of
investing in design
i mean i think what they mentioned is
right you know sometimes they do have uh
issues on uh budget but however you know
i think they are already
i think there is a good progress they
are seeing that design can actually
really add value and transform their
businesses
and they have to continue to really
focus on the heat growth and
transforming themselves so
it is we're getting more and more uh
requests from this
sme um because they all believe um that
design
uh good design set a product their own
product apart from their competitors
so that's when they they come to us and
uh they're willing to to invest
and um and that's that's actually uh
definitely uh growing compared to a
couple of years back
but then how do you quantify something
so qualitative
to say that there is true value i mean
how should
anyone try and go about justifying to
say for example
that yes what i'm doing has quantified
value i'm bringing great returns for the
organization as a whole
and i'm contributing uh largely to the
success
of the of an organization that you're
part of or maybe the people that you're
working for
how do we go about that especially in a
way of design
well from a small business perspective
um
i think one thing is that you can
de-risk the ideas i know d-risk doesn't
sound very exciting but
um if the mindset is there there is
tools and plate and processes now that
you could take an idea
in its infancy get into prototype get in
front of customers
i once witnessed a small company that
had a good investment
really talented developers and they're
very passionate while they wrote their
code
and they invested this i think invested
six months building something that
wasn't comprehensive to a customer
and then they said we need to rebuild it
again they went in the second wave and
they still didn't do it and it was again
not relevant to a customer now even if
they invested four weeks just four weeks
i'm not saying that's the ideal time
and they went through like a lean kind
of design process for quickly rapidly
taking the ideas understanding the
journey getting to prototype test the
ideas
they would have seen a lot of the
fundamental flaws in the design
and the money they would have saved and
for the benefit of building a better
experience
at a shorter period of time would have
been significantly different so that's
something that's very easy to manage
people but
it goes to the mindset in that whoever's
there do they have an openness towards
it
are they willing to to kind of take on
these ways of working
um but in the sense of measuring design
um
it is obviously harder to measure design
and say more traditional areas of
business
but there are many ways that that you
can do it again it's really varying on
what you're trying to measure
so there could be a generic measurement
let's say sales for instance but
if you're designing something different
experiences require different forms of
measurements
and there's multiple ways you can do it
we use things called mps which is just
getting a sense of what's the overall
feel of the experience you know
if you're looking at the data you can
look time on task what is the error rate
and then you can use other forms of
usability testing as well so validating
your ideas
so a lot of methods that you can use and
other forms of data
but it's really relative to what you
want to test and what part of the
experience
right but it's a very good question if
you can measure design
and present it back into metrics to
people from business it gives you a lot
more drive in the business and you get a
lot more buy-in
i i wanted to ask jason this question
because someone is more on product
design and i saw that you are designing
a lot of these
dell bags do you sell more computers
because you've got a great design coming
up from your bags
[Laughter]
i've got to ask you guys right yeah
yeah i i do hope that and there will be
one day where people
buy a computer because they want that
back
[Laughter]
no i think it is possible yeah it is
possible right
lv back comes with a computer laptop
i think i think we do we do see that
that sometimes by people do buy the bags
without the computer so so like because
like we basically
sell it like especially especially um
alienware for example as a gaming brand
all right so
like instead of basically um i'm buying
a universe pc and stuff some some
of them actually likes um the
accessories like bags
uh mines and etc right t-shirts
jackets we do we do see them right so
selling
accessories without a computer yes
that's what we have that's why we have
an accessories business
i i i have a personal experience once uh
someone actually uh this guy was
probably one of those
rare few right he actually bought a a
phone cover which was more expensive
than the phone
so i'm like trying to figure out who's
protecting what actually
and so i realized that design does make
a hell of a lot of difference too
right right well i i mean i wanted to
ask right uh the other parts about
uh in agencies right agencies uh
versus in-house uh design as a
profession
how different is it i mean is is it
is it better or is it different how how
i mean i mean jeju is from the agency
side you're designing for someone which
uh
generally means that the ip you have to
transfer it to somebody else
except for those that you you commission
yourself and versus those that you
design
for in-house for an organization like
jason
and and dale and i think crystal you
partner and you design some of yourself
too right i'm assuming is that correct
so is there a
difference between crystal maybe
would like to try yeah um yeah they're
not exactly the same
um actually but you know of course both
regardless of whether it's
in-house uh focusing on a certain
experience
or whether we are reaching out to um
other brands
is still to assist to to create a
meaningful and memorable and of course
measurable i think that's also what's
very important to
to be able to measure the experience
like what we mentioned earlier
so uh agency of course they are just
focusing on the brand um
i used to be actually working uh no sim
and you know i'm i don't design massage
chair but i should create the retail
experience
for for for osim and it is
a very focused really just on the uh
the retail experiences you know every
product that comes in we have to
we have to um design and uh
you know transform the retail experience
to feed to to suit the product so the
whole um the whole
experience is is much better and of
course for um
for you know uh agency we reach out to a
variety of clients from
multiple brands very diversified group
of
uh various clients from sme to to
uh to um you know international um
client there is
uh a big disciplines and um
yeah it's actually um pretty different
for sure and of course a lot more
exposure when it comes to um
dealing with uh a group of uh multiple
brands
yeah right and maybe i can just ask juju
to
give us a little bit of his thought on
this in in-house
versus agency and then after that we can
shift gears to asking for you for your
personal advice i think there's quite a
bit of questions coming in from that
area
um you're asking about the difference
between in-house and agency designers
yes from your point of view
um i think i think they are
primarily the same the the only
difference is that
you have one client versus multiple
clients but the
the base process is is transferable it's
basically trying to understand what your
client needs what the project
um goal and outcome is and then
structure a process that
uh that gets you there so um although
as an agency as a designer in a in a
consultancy or agency you get multiple
projects multiple clients
but the end thing is is the same you
start with scoping framing and
understanding what is required uh how
you get your client there
um so for me fundamentally it's the same
it's just a matter of do you like to
design
i have a friend who i i used to have
been an agency where the senior was
designing hp printers for
for like 10 years so even in ages you
can be assigned to a client for 10 years
so it really depends on
on your own preference i feel okay thank
you
maybe i can switch gears a little bit
right i think let's talk about the
how to get into this particular space i
mean we've talked about what the
opportunities are i want to focus a
little bit about your personal advice
how what kind of skills you need when
you want to get started in the ux and ui
space
especially okay so let me put a bit of
context
meet careers not just when you're coming
out fresh and then you can learn
everything right and you've got a lot of
space in your brains
to be able to pick up a lot of skills
and stuff for mid careers
if you're trying to switch and to go
into ux ui how would you
advise someone trying to do that to come
into the
design profession
uh questions um well okay so it let so
the question is this if you want to
first go into your midway in your career
somewhere but you want to pivot into
your ux
well well the first thing is that um the
technology is so accessible now that
you can design things on your own accord
so if you have an
idea for a product or an experience you
can do that
you know you can use tools like figma
sketch envision to prototype
and really look at if you haven't looked
at humans and design and design thinking
i really encourage to look at these
methods and processes
and think about some idea perhaps it's
something you're passionate about in
fact that's better if there's something
that you really thought about it and
you've got an idea for a digital
experience whether it's a mobile app or
website
or even an apple watch however you
choose it to be and go through that
process and the most important thing is
to really show your thinking to it
how you came to the ideas how you
validated it where did it come from
and then building an actual prototype so
if you've got visual skills already
understanding how an interface is built
how to use that space
effectively and then if you have a
prototype at the end would even be
even what certainly get my attention is
if you then took that in front of
customers
and you see how people interact with it
and something that's a real penny drop
moment
if you're designing anything for a
customer when you're really close to
something and you become
more knowledge of the craft and you
think others is beautiful this works
and then you put it in front of a
customer and something you thought was
fantastic it doesn't even make sense to
them
and and going through that experience
and then seeing how somebody uses the
prototype
adjusting the design again and having
that type of narrative and story is a
great piece for your portfolio
so i think you can use um easy tools to
create a website portfolio to be
tailored upon ui and ux
and just really just go out your way
build your own experience and build your
own prototype really
with all these areas to really show your
your thinking and your thinking behind
it your problem solving is a real key
part
and that's what i'm really curious about
when i look for new stuff
and but there's lots of community
communities out there get out there
meet people there's different forms that
takes place getting part of the
community and get involved
right crystal i mean you're into a space
of designing a lot of experiences as
well
how how do you think people should get
started what kind of skills should they
pick up first is any
direction you want to point people to
um of course uh for for our industry you
know it's like
uh the desired education they will have
like you know in
um their education in a degree or
a diploma in interior architectural
industrial design visual communication
design communications and all this
uh architecture creative art us ui i
think that is
um some of the foundation that uh we
look up for designers but
ultimately regardless of which are the
industry because we are very diversified
we
we create experience for various clients
in a very
um very messed uh
um various experiences so it is really
to adopt a mindset of continuing uh
transforming
adapting and innovating um so that is
uh important like what i mentioned you
know is design
thinking is really just the only mindset
so um
being innovative you know being
innovative is no longer just
nice to have it's actually absolutely
necessary to have for designers today
so um yeah regardless of that basic
training i think most important is to
to this um the design mindset that the
creative mindset that we might we must
have
right so if someone is may not have that
kind of uh
qualification just yet is it possible to
actually show from some of the related
industries like say
someone is a maybe a fashion designer
who suddenly says
maybe i just don't want to go fast
fashion anymore and i would like to
actually do
design of experiences would that would
be something that we considered
seriously as well
yes yes we actually have designers um
from various disciplines uh whether they
are fashion designers
or product designers or you know in fact
we do
also have a lot of um people in the
studio who are not design trained
but they are so creative so it is
interesting you know
and um and uh that is where we what we
are looking at based on end of the day
we are um we have growth innovators who
really
create values for our client and it's
that type of training the tough uh
innovative and strategic mindset that
help us to reach out to the end user so
it has been a very diversified market
but of course you know
from there it is really the exposure
as well as the the mindset that we we
have all this a group of
um creative people that come together to
to collaborate together to to find the
best
um solutions for us and our customers
right well jason what about you what
kind of qualities would you look out for
i mean you've got quite a
i think sizeable team right it's a it's
actually team based isn't it
yeah yeah so i think really basically
based on the
question the original question he was
talking about like how what how do you
basically transit
mid career into uh different kind of
design
competencies right so like in in dell
itself
or even in a pretty much previous
company like hp
so we do have um like basically a career
switch within the company
right so and there is an international i
mean the multi-disciplinary organization
we do advise that right so that you
could basically switch your career
within the specific company or within
the specific team
right so there are two two things first
thing is more of um you need to kind of
get your core skills
right so that there's definitely a layer
of core skills for uiux you need to have
basically like figma and all these
tools that you kind of use it right as a
basic um uh kind of a ui ux designer you
need to
to kind of build your course skills
first right so and then
experiencing and creating um like
uh what dale has mentioned right so so
basically go create
right so experience it so usually in
dell we will basically
have mentorship and stuff that basically
help designers that that uh
transit into the roles that they want to
be in the future as part of their career
planning
right so um yeah basically the skills
and also the mindset itself has to kind
of switch
right and then and then just just a
quick wrap up for the final question i
think that's the
important one right ultimately whatever
we're doing we're looking
for the mark of success so one of the
questions i have is that how would you
measure
that you have been successful in your
design career
can i post it to all of you a quick
short one or two liners
before i hand it over back to the team
at dsg
successful meaning by i i think the the
most successful
experience that i have is always when
the customers
when you look at customer feedback and
on and all the
kind of reviews and stuff that all the
design thinking that you actually put
into the the product itself
is basically came out from the voice of
that customer
right so so to me i think that that that
feels uh
that we did a good job in basically
translating that
into a customer needs thanks thanks
thanks jason
dale i think you probably say if similar
if you created a product that
exceeds what the customer expected of
the product
and entailed actually new behavior i
think that's when you've really driven
design to actually change
somebody's life in some form from a team
perspective
building a team that's actually
collaborative is actually generating
good work it goes to the product i like
it design of new behaviors
yeah that's a new one i like that
i i'm very at the moment but i'm yet i'm
very intrigued by it at the same time
crystal what about yours
so for me the uh really to create a
memorable uh experience for our
customers i mean it's like some
you know experience that would touch
their heart i think that was the
probably um you know the most successful
things that we have done
um for our customers and they keep
coming back to us
i think that is the most important and
we feel really appreciated
and you know that the passion uh that
fire just keeps us
going right thank you that's the last
yeah the final say um yeah for for me
it's uh
it's getting the client um to the next
step
so i we used to always think that uh
it's the you know you need to have a big
win
but we realized that design is to get
you to the next step so you could get on
to your next next step or open up more
doors for you
um so with that uh kind of my second
mind the success
part doesn't take too much um kind of
like burden but it's like okay let's
focus on what gets you next
um and then we will take it from there
right thank you everyone thank you for
all your candid sharing and a wonderful
advice i'm sure all the
listeners and people who have attended
to our session today
who have learned so much from it i'm
sure that there's a lot of questions
that you still have
uh still keep them coming into your q
and a we'll try to respond as much as
possible after this session
meanwhile i hand it over back to the
to the dsg team over to you
thanks ryan and hi everyone again i will
now be sharing with you on the design
singapore scholarship which supports
aspiring designers
design practitioners and design
advocates in their professional
development journey
the dsg scholarship supports formal
education and design
to groom design leaders who strive to
make things better and contribute to
singapore and the design sector
applicants must be a singapore citizen
or permanent resident
have completed national service for male
applicants and have successfully gained
admission to a full-time undergraduate
or postgraduate design related course
meaning a bachelor's master's or phd
program that is offered locally or
overseas by a reputable institution
the 2021 application cycle is open from
now till 19 april 2021.
next piece under the scholarship there
is a holistic support framework put in
place for our scholars
in terms of financial coverage it will
be in these five areas
firstly full tuition fee and also travel
allowance to cover airfare to and from
the country of study
pre-studies allowance for settling in
computer and warm clothing
developmental cost allowance for
self-development programs outside of
school
and leaving allowance to cover living
expenses in the country of study
next piece for our scholars development
journey
we will assign a body from the design
singapore associates network
which is the network of all dsg scholars
whether they have graduated or are still
studying
and they will come together to
collaborate exchange ideas
and organize events for both the design
community and the community at large
there is also a compulsory one-month
internship to be served in singapore
during studies
for application of knowledge and
on-the-job experience
on top of this dsg will also facilitate
other mentorship and job matching
opportunities
next please as for the bond to be served
it should be a full-time design related
role in a singapore registered company
whether it is an sme an mnc with
singapore base
or setting up your own studio the bomb
period depends on the country of study
and the duration of sponsorship
so if you look on the screen in summary
a local
scholarship recipient must fulfill a two
or three year bond
and an overseas overseas scholarship
receiver must fulfill a three or five
year bond
next teeth we would also like to take
the opportunity to share that we will be
holding an online briefing session
in early march to answer any questions
you may have on the dsg scholarship
in the meantime you can write to us at
the email shown on the screen here to
register your interest in attending
you may scan the smaller qr code on the
left to capture the email
details as for more information on the
dsg scholarship
you can scan the qr code on the right to
visit our webpage
i will now hand the time over to mr
junior lim from the lifelong learning
institute
to share on the skills and training
advice we made available by the lli
junior please
hope you can hear me all right so
thanks for staying on
so i'm from can i the next slide please
okay so huh my name is julie i'm from
the
uh skills and training advisory unit
with the lifelong learning institute
excuse which in singapore
so basically next slide please
what i'm here to do today is to actually
share with you
on a service brought to you by skill
switches singapore
so it's actually what we call the skills
and training advisory
so it's really the whole purpose of it
is to help individuals like you
singaporeans
to really identify your skills training
needs if you want to upgrade up skill
or i think what the panelists have
shared earlier on in terms of
reinventing yourself if you are a career
entrant
keen to move into the design sector i'm
not sure how to do it
well we are here to help you so what
does this skills and training advisory
entails
next slide please so
what it entails is one you will actually
be able to receive
a personalized guidance uh in terms of
advisory in terms
of what are your current academic
qualifications
uh do you need any bridging causes or do
you want to learn a new skill
what causes available uh is is
that the trainings available for you and
which
training partner actually offers such
training then
if you are still uncertain whether
design is something for you well
the skills ambassadors offering the
skills and training advisory services
are able to help you discover your
career interests and goals
or to do a bit of what we call career
planning
identify the needs
training referrals and of course end of
the day to give you the right
tools and resources so that you can
embark on your own journey ahead
next slide please so when i talk about
uh you know in a nutshell what we do
it's really your career plan
so we will help you to go through things
such as our self-reflection
goal setting and of course develop a
plan
so self-reflection is really about doing
a stop take in your life today
uh i think we are all busy rushing from
day-to-day work
uh commitments uh routines that we're
all
embracing but uh reflection is a key to
success
it's not only just reflecting about your
career path but also reflecting
about yourself identifying things such
as your values
interest and personality and when you
begin to understand yourself
what you want then you'll be more easily
able to create a plan that suits your
goals and your lifestyle
so that's where the goal setting comes
in so goal settings of course
we always talk about very commonly smart
goals
specific measurable attainable uh
relevant and of course time bound but
what we are actually here to encourage
in terms of goal setting is to go beyond
just setting a goal
but rather sharing it sharing it with a
loved one a friend
a buddy or even a skills ambassador
whereby we can actually then help you
guide you and possibly nudge you along
your journey
ahead and of course having a
self-reflection you know what you want
you set goal this is what i
wish to have then we actually develop a
plan to actually
achieving that it can be considered
in a more technical term sometimes some
individual individuals will actually say
it's like
reverse engineering but it's really
about planning the specific steps to
take
to attaining that goal that you have
already planned
and that's career planning in a nutshell
so if you really need more help well
under skills and training advisory
services the skills ambassadors are
really really here to help you
next slide please so to help you
travel or move into uh the skills
framework for design
uh into the design sector i think where
ck's region singapore has come up with
is actually a skills framework for
design
so this is actually uh i wouldn't say uh
it's a
structure a map of the design sector
what it entails
and if you are keen to move in what do
you require to take
so that it will actually help you in
your journey ahead
so it offers things such as sector
information career pathways
potential occupation job roles uh
emerging skills
and of course if you want to upgrade
yourself who are the partners that
actually help
so if you are keen to know more you can
always scan the qr code to actually
download the pdf copy
of the entire framework and then you can
view it in your own
moving on next so
what we are also looking at is also
certain skills that can cut across
different
sectors or different professions within
the design
so what are we looking at more
importantly are the portable skills
and the attributes so one of the few
things if you're keen to move
into as a new entrant or a mid-career
individual
these are some of the attributes that
potential employers are actually looking
at
and how we tangible uh or
make things make the creative aspects
or traits tangible so that employers can
actually
identify it and know exactly these are
the traits that
you have next slide please
of course next with the we've covered i
think there are a lot of
new skills new uh information new skills
and demand
so likewise in the skills framework we
are also looking at
the relevant skills that were cut across
in the various careers in the design
sectors as well
so skills such as business model
innovation all the way down to system
thinking
these are actually going to be new
skills or skills that is actually
in demand with the respective design
companies that they are looking at
and this will definitely value at
whether you are in the current sector as
a designer
or keen to move into these sectors of
work next slide please
so overall under the skills framework
there are actually four key tracks that
we are looking at
and most of our panel the four panelists
that we had
actually do fit into this so we have the
business design innovation and
technology
uh pathways as well to know more
do log on to download the skills
framework for design and actually uh
read it up on your own
uh these are really resources that
actually gives you a better
insight and understanding into the
sector next please
okay to help you out in terms of getting
new skills upscaling or even reinventing
yourself
so what happens is we do have something
called the skills future credit as a
singaporean citizen
if you are 25 and above you would have
received
at least five to a thousand credits
available for you to use in your journey
for upgrading
so how do you actually use it or how do
you identify it
next slide please
my excuse future this is our portal uh
developed and designed by
skillsusa singapore to actually help
singaporeans in terms of their upgrading
journey
so how do you want to use the skills
future credit
what causes to take if you have
identified the
new skills that you're keen on log on to
the portal the resources are there for
you to
search for courses that can be used
using your skills really credit to
offset the cost of it
and overcome your training inertia helps
you to
discover yourself explore sectors so if
you want more details on the skills
framework
for design it's actually also found on
our portal
also equipping you with career tips and
resources to stay ahead
to prepare yourself in terms of your job
application and of course if you are
keen
it is also able to route you to our
portal to look for certain
suitable jobs based on your skill sets
as well
so this is the online version that we
have in terms of resources that
is ever ready any time you need
but if you need someone to really speak
to really explore more
then next time please come and speak to
us
we have our skills and messages
available we do have a free
30-45 minute session and these are
catered to you
individually all you need to do is scan
the qr code that's on your screen right
now
or visit the link indicated below and
key in
at the last question how did you hear
about us dsg
so we'll know that this is actually you
have actually uh
this is our attended this webinar and we
can then actually contact you
with the relevant resources and
assistance to help you further
so with that being said i will hand you
back over to dsg
to wrap up the session
thank you junior for your sharing and
thank you very much to our wonderful
panel
ryan crystal dale jason and jeru
i'm sure those who are present with us
today have enjoyed hearing from you
firsthand on your personal experiences
in design roles
the exciting opportunities within the
design sector post pandemic
and the importance of in career planning
and continuous learning
we have come to the end of our session
and we will appreciate it if you could
take some time to share your feedback on
the session through a quick survey
by scanning the qr code on the left and
lastly
if you would like to find out more about
the programs the national design center
has lined up for february
under the theme of design learning
please do scan the qr code that you see
on the right
thank you once again for spending your
thursday afternoon with us
and we hope to see you at our future
events goodbye
you